when I am man premiered in 2008 and no
one could have possibly anticipated its
influence now what have been predicted
to be a mildly successful btf film our
best has a distinction of anchoring one
of the most successful franchises in
film history so what's with the curious
absence of a fourth Iron Man movie let's
dig through the gossip and find out what
we never got to see I am and for pricey
playboy Robert Downey jr. as value to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe can't be
overstated since he's been the
charismatic center of the Avengers
initiative this on-screen value however
comes with a real-world price tag as
Tony Stark
Downey hasn't just been one of the most
valuable players in the Marvel stable
he's become one of the most valuable
actors in the entire world even modest
estimates have his earning capacity at
hundreds of millions of dollars it will
be no surprise of the cost-benefit
analysis of another Iron Man for Marvel
sideshows less and less of a reward
fortunately the end of Downey's
involvement wouldn't have to spell the
end for a big screen iron man his
version beloved as it is it's just a
part of Iron Man's legacy rather than a
role that ends with his departure as
others have been known to step into his
rocky shoes basically I'm here to
announce that we're building Iron Man
I'm gonna blast off in a second too many
heroes if you're a fan of Marvel movies
you've likely heard about their strategy
of releasing films and phases phase one
was the original Avengers Assemble are
introducing our main heroes Phase two
leading up to age of Ultron broaden that
world taking us into space and
introducing new heroes like and mer now
we're in phase three set to introduce a
slew of new heroes culminating with the
long-awaited battle against Thanos in
2018 Avengers infinity war meanwhile a
Captain America has already had his
third adventure and Thor will also see
his third movie before phase 4 begins
add Black Panther and Captain Marvel's
upcoming solo movies and it's hard to
see how another Iron Man could easily
fit into the mix short on villains bad
guys have never really been the strong
point of the MCU they're all fairly
OneNote and most of their master plans
boil down to blowing up buildings for 20
minutes before getting their butts
handed to them by the heroes the sort of
running out of interesting and
impressive villains that
civic to iron month there are still
interesting directions they can go but
throwing a giant angry hovering head
into the MCU seems unlikely that is a
very big head and most of Tony Stark's
other enemies are just other dudes and
super suits and there's no way that
we'll ever see them throw a giant dragon
like Fin Fang Foom into the MCU or would
they shorts on good storylines Iron
Man's most famous storylines of mostly
already made it to the big screen for
better or for worse ARMA wars was
loosely adapted for the premise of Iron
Man 2 demon in a bottle where Tony Stark
confronted alcoholism has been addressed
throughout the series you know the
question I get asked most often is Tony
how do you go to the bathroom shoot just
okay extremis was a pretty big part of
our month 3 at this point Marvel might
be kind of tapped out would it be a good
idea to go more obscure can movie-going
audiences deal with tony stark being
mind-controlled by Kang the Conqueror
and beating up his teenage self could it
be Marvel would rather not push its luck
find out in the next episode of and a
necessary risk the Iron Man trilogy is
in critics eyes a 3 for 3 success story
which is no small task as the makers of
the spider-man x-men and Batman
franchises how well their third
installments went
not even the Godfather was as consistent
as Ironman executives may be hesitant to
risk that perfect record because they
stand to lose more than they stand to
gain it's easy to make bad superhero
movies of terrible plot contrivance ease
hey but the conclusion of Iron Man 3
felt like a smart final statement for
the character as a solo hero and the
insane action sequence in which Starks
summons an army of robot controlled Iron
Man suits are saving from an unstable
explosive villain seems kind of
impossible to top we don't need Iron Man
for not really the next best thing is
right around the corner thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and don't forget to check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love -
promise